[Música]
quién de los que está aquí en la sala en
el auditorio no tiene actualmente un
objetivo o una meta que cumplir
es muy difícil que alguien no tenga una
meta un objetivo de hecho se dice que si
en alguna parte de tu vida no tienes una
meta un objetivo un ideal que quiere
realizar pues estás muerto en vida
estos objetivos cambian de acuerdo al
tiempo tus objetivos eran muy diferentes
cuando tú tenías nueve años por ejemplo
y son muy diferentes ahora
todos hemos querido emprender algo hemos
querido ser algún proyecto y bueno
evidentemente existen muchas etapas en
primera instancia hay que planear la
después
tenemos que
ejecutarla
sin embargo existen errores tenemos que
volver a insistir
existen también frustraciones
tenemos que igual
vernos con esto no tenemos
éxitos tal vez
sin embargo muchas veces cuando estamos
muy apasionados por nuestro proyecto
queremos hacerlo mucho mejor
volvemos al principio entonces al final
tenemos un ciclo iterativo infinito si
es que nos gusta mucho nuestro proyecto
donde podemos seguir mejorando
bueno nunca vamos a llegar a tenerlo
perfecto siempre va a ser
perfectible no bueno ahora es muy
diferente
y hacer un proyecto para tu universidad
que te está obligando el profesor o
hacer un proyecto donde tú sientes y
quieres hacerlo quieres hacer una
investigación quieres hacer una empresa
quieres mejorar tu empresa porque no
puede ser un proyecto no quieres empezar
un emprendimiento bueno en realidad yo
quise hacer eso más o menos a mis 21
años 22 tampoco soy también jugar un
poquito nada más en realidad
lo primero que me habían dicho era que
trabaje duro si quieres conseguir tu
meta tienes que trabajar duro
llamas después me di cuenta que en
realidad esa no era
la idea la idea es trabajar de manera
inteligente más que trabajar muy duro
bueno como se podrán imaginar mi
proyecto era destinado a software era
algo de tecnología bueno yo quería hacer
mi primer proyecto y el proyecto era una
aplicación móvil para android y también
para rayos
sin duda como todo chico que empieza a
ser un proyecto yo estaba muy motivado
estaba aquí para conquistar el mundo con
este proyecto
sin embargo me dado cuenta de una cosa
al mes de hacer el proyecto
que nadie sabe todo
en realidad por
más capaz o por más motivación que
tengas tú no puedes ser bueno en todo un
futbolista no puede ser arquero defensa
volante y delantero a la vez no puede
ser bueno en todos los puestos un
ingeniero civil no puede ser un experto
haciendo puentes haciendo represas
haciendo edificios a la vez siempre hay
algo donde tú te especializas bueno en
realidad este también era mi contexto si
quería ser una aplicación móvil buena no
podía hacerlo yo solo por más que
quisiera no es ahí donde
nace una palabra que se me agrava mucho
que es el equipo
tenía que hacer un equipo no solamente
yo podría programar algo sino que tenía
que tener varios amigos que estén
haciendo algo conmigo no
en este tendido
bueno tenía que armar el equipo
en primera instancia quería que mi
aplicación se vea buena entonces le
hablé a un amigo el diseñador capi ximo
se llama pedro camargo
y después tenía que tener a alguien capi
ximo en desarrollo en el back en bases
de datos entonces llamé un amigo más
conocí a alguien que no era mi tan amigo
pero era muy bueno desarrollando lo
llame
y bueno tenía a alguien conocía a
alguien en sucre que estaba más o menos
viendo lo que era you so experience
experiencia de usuario y bueno también
lo llamé
sin embargo
todos los que están en tu equipo tienen
que compartir tu mismo objetivo es muy
difícil llegar a algo cuando en tu
equipo no todos reman hacia donde tú
quieres
el momento donde alguien quiere algo en
el equipo muy diferente a los demás pues
bueno ya es muy difícil hacer
y las cosas
en este entendido
este mi primer proyecto he enseñado la
importancia del equipo estoy seguro que
para tener el éxito hay muchos factores
más sin embargo estoy convencido que un
punto fundamental es el equipo no puedes
hacer algo muy bueno solo
bueno
no importa el contexto donde estés
nosotros hemos empezado así
tenemos más cabello ahí pero
lo importante es que tengas voluntad que
todos estén motivados y que todo se
apunten a un mismo lugar que todos
piensen en un objetivo común
efectivamente todos tienen que estar
alegres a pesar de las limitaciones que
tengas el momento en que alguien se
sienta desanimado pues tenemos que tener
una charla con él porque si hay alguien
que está con mala vibra entonces todo el
proyecto se va a ir abajo
tampoco todo es tan fácil no crean que
si tienes un equipo donde se llevan bien
todos son carísimos o quieren aprender
muy rápido va a estar bien todo pues hay
noches donde tienes que amanecer hay
veces donde todos se tienen que sentar y
decir creo que esto no va a funcionar
tenemos que cambiar de rumbo o tenemos
que cambiar de tecnología pues si existe
es pero siempre todos debemos ser
propositivos en el equipo y si todos
vamos con voluntad con entusiasmo y con
una meta clara entonces las cosas van a
ir mejorando poco a poco cada vez
las puertas se te van a abrir cada vez
va a ser mejorando
la clave es insistir no ir mejorando ir
mejorando y bueno hasta que puedes
encontrar un objetivo
esta aplicación móvil que estábamos
haciendo hace unos cuantos años pues
bueno ha sido una de las primeras o tal
vez la única aplicación móvil de sucre
la cual ha sido comprada por una empresa
transnacional y ahora está funcionando
en holanda en amsterdam y bueno una vez
que alcanza este objetivo pues si no
tienes más objetivos eres una persona
muerte en vida entonces tienes que
seguir viendo a dónde ir tienes que
seguir poniendo te metas objetivos
ideales mucho más más más grandes y
bueno sin duda
además de que tu equipo es la clave para
tu proyecto tu equipo también es
muy fundamental para construir la
persona que tú eres está demostrado que
somos el resultado de las personas con
las que más frecuenta vamos entonces si
tú estás metido en un proyecto si tú
tienes un equipo con lo que
prácticamente vives con él además de tu
familia pues bueno muchas de las cosas
que tú
eres
vas a copiar de ellos
es
muy bueno haber conocido a ese mi primer
equipo si bien ahora trabajamos en
proyectos bien aislados estoy seguro que
muchas de las cosas que yo soy que yo
hago y como pienso son gracias a ellos
entonces hay que alejarnos de las
personas negativas no podemos hacer un
proyecto con ellos no pueden ser parte
de nuestro equipo porque además de
mandar a la basura tu proyecto de
investigación no sé también te estás un
poco yendo retroceso tú mismo porque en
realidad tú eres también tu equipo
y bueno ahora no solamente pensemos en
equipo
o en las personas que están dentro de tu
proyecto qué pasa con los otros equipos
bueno en realidad también me ha tocado
ver que muchas personas piensan que yo
tengo mi equipo existen otros equipos
y estos equipos son mis enemigos los
tengo que pisar
esto es totalmente falso
estoy seguro de que en cualquier ámbito
de la vida
todos siendo amigos y no poniendo los
trabas entre entre nosotros podemos
alcanzar el éxito estoy convencido de
que el éxito no solamente tiene una
sillita nada más sino hay muchas donde
todos podemos alcanzar el éxito no
entonces nuestro único el mundo ahora en
el siglo 21 no exige esa mentalidad el
siglo 21 ahora te exige otra mentalidad
donde tu único enemigo son los problemas
explícitos y latentes de la sociedad del
medio ambiente de tu entorno
entonces si tú piensas y analizas cómo
resolver esos problemas pues bueno vas a
tener éxito en tu proyecto en tu
investigación o no se van a acabar los
problemas en el mundo por ende siempre
vas a tener alguna oportunidad de
negocio algún aporte en el proyecto
alguna oportunidad de investigación este
último
muy centrado en la en la robótica
competitiva y la robótica competitiva es
muy competitiva hay equipos que están 24
horas sin dormir haciendo algo sin
embargo el siglo 21 no solamente te pide
competición no solamente puntúa esas
olimpiadas mundiales la competición sino
también puntúan la cooperación un equipo
que no coopera con los demás equipos
pues bueno jamás va a estar en el podio
actualmente en un campeonato mundial de
robótica de hecho ahora los ingenieros y
los científicos a nivel mundial que
están en la parte competitiva
manejan una nueva palabra una palabra
que viene de la de la combinación de
competición y cooperación que en inglés
sería compartido
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y